it's so exciting that's just really
exciting for me it's really exciting i'm
excited about it
oh it's exciting all right just three
months after announcing the end of their
e-reality show keeping up with the
kardashians
the kardashian jenners have signed on to
a new exclusive deal that will bring the
famous family
back to our tv screens say bible
bible here's the rundown kris jenner and
her daughters kim
chloe and kourtney kardashian and
kendall and kylie jenner
have signed a huge deal with disney to
star
and executive produce a new reality
series for hulu in the us
and star everywhere else isn't that
crazy
the news was announced thursday at
disney's investor day
with chris courtney and chloe all
sharing the big update on instagram as
well
just tune in because you never know
what's gonna happen while details are
scarce
the new kardashian jenner series is
expected to debut
in late 2021 i love it as for keeping up
it's set to wrap up on e earlier next
year with the 20th and final season
a source tells e.t quote the kardashians
decided to leave e because they wanted a
better deal monetarily speaking
the family is really excited about this
new chapter and adventure
and of course are not looking to get out
of the spotlight
they'll still continue to share about
their lives through the deal with hulu
but now with a new
updated spin the number 20.
um it just seemed like the right time i
think
for us to take a minute and breathe and
everybody slow down a bit not slow down
professionally but just you know
figure out what our next steps are and
all of that the kardashians announced
that keeping up was coming to an
end back in september that same month
when et spoke with keeping up
executive producer ryan seacrest he
dished on the family's choice to say
goodbye
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
you look back at 14 years and 20 seasons
of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're going to say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're going to live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it
you